So today we'll be speaking
with Dr Jennifer Learner,
a professor of public
policy and management at the
Harvard Kennedy School of
Government on emotion and judgment.
Dr Lerner is a professor of public policy
and management at the Harvard Kennedy
School of Government,
as well as the founder and former
director of the Harvard Laboratory for
decision science.
This interdisciplinary laboratory,
which she cofounded with two economists,
draws primarily on psychology, economics,
and neuroscience to study human
judgment and decision making.
Dr Lerner publishes her research
widely and scientific journals,
summaries of which appear in popular
print, such as the New York Times,
as well as broadcast media
such as good morning America.
She also serves on the editorial boards
for the Journal of Personality and
social psychology,
organizational behavior and human
decision processes and the Journal of
Behavioral Decision Research. She's
received numerous awards for her research,
including the presidential early career
award for scientists and engineers and
in a White House ceremony,
the National Science Foundation and the
president of the United States annually
confer this award as the highest national
honor for investigators in the early
stages of promising research careers.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview on emotion and judgment with
Dr Jennifer Learner.
So welcome Jen. Thank you for
speaking with us today. Thank you.
So what I wanted to start out asking you
was just a little bit about what first
got you interested in emotion. Um,
where did it all begin for you? Okay,
so I hadn't had actually
intended to study emotion.
I was in graduate school
and it was working with bill
Tetlock is my advisor and
I was trying to study
more outweighed really,
I was interested in attitudes
and judgment and decision making.
We were looking at legal cases
trying to understand, um,
you know,
the psychology behind people's judgments
and we kept trying to prime moral
outrage in the lab.
And um,
so we were writing all of
these scenarios very serious,
been yet giving them to
subjects in the pilot tests,
came back with meager results and nobody
was outraged based on the things that
they were reading.
And what I discovered is,
is that they were to cognitive and I
went to see Bob Levenson also on the
faculty at Berkeley.
And I say,
I can't get these people to be
morally outraged. And he said, well,
that's because you need to study emotion.
Um,
unless you invoke emotion systems,
they're not,
not going to get a strong
response, more or less age, uh,
is in many ways viscerally mediated and
you've got to trigger these systems.
So it was just huge awakening for me.
And,
um,
it turns out that while I was in
Grad school at Berkeley psychology,
it was, um, you know, just kind
of a mecca. Uh, it still is,
it's even more so for emotion research.
And so I had wonderful
intellectual resources,
um,
a lot of great advice and that was
how I started studying emotion.
And then I realized emotion
is what I wanted to study. Um,
I just didn't know it.
And there you were a serendipitously
in one of the most fantastic emotion
research centers in the
country. Yes. Fantastic.
Yes. Bob Always gives people some of
the best career advice possible. Um,
I've been there too and he helps shape
everyone towards emotion, which is great.
Yes. So I wanted to ask
you about your research,
which really has pioneered
important discoveries in
our understanding of emotion
and how it relates to judgements.
So you are widely known for developing
this really exciting and novel framework
to understand how and why emotions
influenced judgment and decision making,
which you referred to as the
appraisal tendency framework.
And I wondered if you could share a
little bit about what you see as the core
principles of this framework.
Sure. Well, um,
the most important core principle is
that specific emotions can be related to
specific judgment and decision making
outcomes in predictable lawful ways.
And the key to making those correct
predictions is to understanding the
underlying structure of any given emotion.
So,
um,
most importantly,
we have looked at the cognitive
structure of different emotions.
And what we've predicted and found
is that the cognitive structure in
particular,
the appraisal structure,
so some emotions are high and
appraisals of certainty. For example,
anger is a prime example of that.
That sense of certainty associated with
the active emotional state carries over
and influences how individuals
perceive new situations.
So if I'm feeling angry,
I'm going to perceive more of a
sense of certainty in new situations.
And we call that process the
carryover of incidental emotion.
I wondered if you could
say a little bit more about
this distinction between
integral versus Internet,
incidental influences
on emotion in judgments.
Sure. So, um,
we think of incidental emotion as
something like I just described.
You're driving into work,
somebody cuts you off to your car,
you're mad,
then you finally get into the office,
he had the meeting that
involves a question of whether
you and your company are
going to take a particular risk.
So somebody hitting your car that morning
should have no bearing on the decision
for whether you're going to
take this risk. But in fact,
even though that emotion should be
incidental to the meeting decision,
it typically carries over and
influences it. And in the case of anger,
we know that when people are mad,
even if the source of the anger
should be normatively unrelated,
um,
it makes people more risk taking.
So you'd be more likely to take a risk
and your company than if you were in a
neutral state.
And certainly more likely than if you
were in a fearful state because fear is
associated with lack of certainty.
So what this framework does is it allows
us to link what's known about risk
perception and risk taking,
things like the role that certainty
and controllability play with different
emotional states.
And then we can make much
more accurate predictions.
Now you might predict the same thing
in the case of integral emotion and it
might be a stronger effect,
but let's say you were,
uh,
driving to work accident,
you're mad,
then you have to make a decision about
whether to change your insurance on your
car. That would be an
example of integral emotion.
So the anger that you're
feeling is normatively relevant.
It's defensible as an influence on your
decision regarding the car insurance. So,
so that's the difference.
So interesting. I mean,
it also makes me think of other work
that you've done. Again, more seminal,
important worth looking at the
relationship between emotion and economic
judgments as well. And I wonder, you
know, if you could say more here,
the ways in which emotions shape our sort
of everyday, you know, purse strings.
So to spare. Sure. Well,
one of the things I'm just,
that I'm interested in doing is bringing
a greater understanding of how emotion
works in the brain to um,
expand our knowledge,
but also,
uh,
more specifically just solve common
public policy program, um, problems.
So one problem that we have is that people
don't value the future enough so we
don't save enough in the present and we
spend too much in the
present. Um, and we also,
when we have opportunities to get more,
um,
later, then, um, we could get,
now we don't like to delay
that gratification and so
we just take less amount of
a lower dollar amount today then we could
take in the future if we were willing
to eat.
Um,
this relates to some of the classic
experiments done in psychology,
like Michelle's marshmallow study where
the kids are allowed to have more cookie.
He's, if they can wait to eat them. Well,
it turns out that adults do
the same thing all the time.
They don't wait to eat them.
Um,
and we do it with real money and this
is a problem in our national economy.
And so we have discovered
in our experiments that
sadness actually increases
this tendency.
And um,
sadness in general has very strong
effects on how people spend their money.
We always use real money and we use no
deception and we follow all of the very
well specified procedures in economics
because we like our work to be relevant
to economists as well as psychologists.
And what we've shown across many studies,
we now have three papers,
um,
dealing with sadness and economic
decision making published in psychological
science.
Um,
what we find is that sadness has what you
would call irrational effects and it's
incidental sadness and decision makers
do not recognize the impact they,
um,
if you ask them how is it
sadness influencing the
prices you said or that sort
of thing, they deny the
influence of sadness. Wow.
So we're very interested in this and
later this semester I'll be going to the
White House by invitation to meet with
folks from the Council of economic
advisors to the president.
And thinking about how basic understanding
of emotion and economic decision
making can help us to think about
crafting some public policy interventions.
That's fantastic.
I mean,
just hearing that this work can also
have real world kind of, you know,
policy level implications too. Yes. So my,
my major career goal is to learn
more about how the mind works,
especially in the area of emotion
and decision making and to make that
information useful for the common good.
And that's one of the reasons I work
at a policy school rather than, um,
another place that I might work is
because I like having the direct impact.
I teach military commanders,
government officials from all over the
world and get that information to them
before they have to week to read about
it three years later. Right? Yes.
The publishing scientific papers
can take a while as you know.
So the last
question I just wanted to ask, I mean,
you touched on this already, but I mean,
I wanted to touch a little bit more again
about your work that's looked at the
impact of emotions on judgment,
including risk perception.
And I wondered if you wanted to say
anything else about the role of these
distinct categories of emotions on,
you know,
the way in which it influences
our perception of risks?
Sure. Like so your anger.
Yeah,
sure.
So fear in anger are both negative
emotions. And when I came into the field,
those standard prediction would be
because their negative emotions,
they should trigger pessimism because
a negative feeling leads to a negative
global outlook.
Um,
but that did not seem right to me
because the of what I knew about the
underlying structures,
I mean angers and approach emotion.
Fear is they withdrawal emotion.
Um,
anger is associated with a sense of
certainty and individual control.
Appraisals. When people are mad, they
don't question themselves and you know,
they really think they know what's going
on. There's fears associated with them.
It's a defined by a sense of uncertainty
and lack of individual controlled.
And those cognitive metta
factors control and certainty.
We know no drive
perceptions of risk. So, um,
along with Dacher Keltner we predicted
and found that fear and anger actually
have opposite effects on risk perception.
Also on risk taking.
And so this, uh, uh,
is one of the most important
findings that we, uh,
we have in terms of supporting the
framework and the need to look in a
desegregated way within emotional
valence and separate out,
it's not all negative emotions have
the same effects and not all positive
emotions have the same effects.
So it's really important to tease these
apart if you want to make accurate
predictions for judgment and decision
making outcomes. For example,
we've done another set of studies
that compares sadness with disgust.
They're both negative emotions,
but they have very different
effects on buying price discussed.
Her suppresses buying
price, again, real money,
and that is increases buying price.
So there's a number of studies like that
in terms of the fear and anger we have.
Um, that's another one where we've
worked on some policy implications.
We've done a nationwide field experiment
where we randomly assigned people to
different emotion conditions
and we've presented that work,
excuse me,
at NATO headquarters and um,
a variety of places around the world.
Um,
also for the United Nations
Training Institute, um,
for various government workers who are
trying to understand the psychological,
biological,
behavioral responses that people have
to terrorism and threats and risk,
that sort of thing.
Right.
So it sounds like this has
really important implications
for sort of the public
communication
and perception of risk.
Absolutely.
We found that we can essentially shape
people's policy preferences and their
perception of risk by randomly assigning
them to one emotional condition versus
another.
Wow.
Which is quite a sort of awesome
and humbling thing to be able to do.
Really powerful too that you can
manipulate it, you know, that easily. Yes.
Wow.
So what I wanted to ask you a bit,
I mean it's been really interesting
hearing sort of what got you into emotion,
all the discoveries you've
made in this realm of emotion,
judgment and risk perception and
decision making. And I wonder, you know,
as you've made these discoveries,
if you were to project sort of where
the future of emotions headed, what,
what might you,
what might you say to that?
Well,
um,
we are a relatively new field and um,
you know, for most of the 20th
century it was pretty much dormant.
You couldn't even buy,
um,
Darwin's book and um,
uh,
emotion and people like skinnier sort
of squashed the study of emotion.
So one thing I would say is that we've
made enough progress now that it won't
disappear. Yeah. And um,
so I would say if anything we're going
to see more courses being offered at
universities. I think it's going
to be very interdisciplinary.
And um,
what I hope is that the wheat from the
chaff can be separated because so many
people are now interested in emotion.
There's a lot of kind of pop stuff
going on and marketers making money on
emotion types of assessments that are
not necessarily scientifically valid.
So I guess I'm being negative
here and telling you not so much,
but I think we'll see you.
But what I hope to not see
and saw also important.
Yeah. So, um, those are
some of my thoughts.
I think it's telling though that a
place like the Harvard Kennedy School of
Government would hire
an emotion researcher.
You inhale because in the past that was
just considered to be sort of fluff and
now people are understanding
there's a real, um,
science and the science is useful.
So then the last question I want to
ask you is a little bit related to the
future and so far as I'm sure you have
students come to you all the time asking
you for advice.
They're interested in emotion,
considering whether or not they want
to embark in this field. What do
you tell them? Yeah, so, um,
I tell them great.
And um,
I often tell them go to Berkeley or go
to Carnegie Mellon or go to Ucla because
those are the places where I got my
training and I'm so fortunate to have
benefited from that training.
I just had amazing mentors.
And,
um,
another thing I tell them is don't rest
on assumptions of what is kind of taken
for granted in the field. You know?
So when I came into the field,
there were some very influential models
about how valence of emotion predicted
judgement or decision making outcomes.
And I didn't accept the assumptions of
those models because it really didn't
seem right to me.
The more I learned,
and I'm still,
I think our research has
a long way to go in, um,
testing the hypotheses that
flow from the framework.
But I think it's really important.
People have so many lay
intuitions about emotion, um,
to not rest on those lay intuitions
and to not rest on even some of the
assumptions in the academic
literature about emotion. It is,
it needs to be all of these things
tested just as rigorously as if you were
shutting synapses and,
um,
and don't be kind of, um, you know,
uh,
sort of seduced into accepting some of
the lay or even scientific intuitions.
Well, I just want to say thank you so
much for speaking with us today, Jen.
It's been a real pleasure. It's
been a pleasure for me. Thank you.
So this concludes our experts and emotion
interview with Doctor Jennifer Learner
from the Harvard Kennedy
School of Government.